[Music]
let out the vegas
in you
las vegas is coming back to life las
vegas is
the lvcva as you just saw there as a new
ad campaign it's called vegas u
inviting visitors to enjoy life to the
fullest and come back to the valley
joining us this morning as you see there
fletch brunell from the vp of marketing
with the lvcva
fletch good morning to you thanks for
joining us this morning we appreciate it
john thanks for having me this morning
so fletch let's talk about the ad it's
obviously being seen here in the valley
it's being seen
around the country presumably tell us
what went into it and what it's uh
what it's hoping to do so we're trying
to do is illustrate how las vegas is the
place for visitors to come back and
basically get back to a normal life
when you think about the past year and
being at home and during the pandemic
people knew that they they couldn't do
what they typically wanted to do so this
is an opportunity for las vegas to offer
visitors
experiences like nowhere else
researchers told us that
people are really ready to travel it's
great that the vaccines
are working effectively and for us as
you mentioned
we're running this at it started
yesterday it is running nationally
it's on network and cable it's on cbs
espn
uh nhl on nbc sports nb a on tnt
so a lot of places where people are
going to see las vegas and we're very
excited about the program
i'm wondering also if there's a
different way of doing that marketing
when you're trying to tell the rest of
the country for example about las vegas
not that they don't already know about
us but
given the fact that we are still in a
pandemic people are starting to feel
safe again is there a bit of a
difference in how you
message and how you talk about las vegas
now versus say
two years ago the the main message for
las vegas has always been adult freedom
so it continues to be the message and
we'll
always have the safety measures in place
and we will talk about how you can come
to vegas safely
but at the end of the day it really is
that people are ready to get back to
their adult freedom
and to find that that vegas is really
what they need people need to get back
to a normal life
and want to experience las vegas and for
uh the great locations on the ad of the
venetian circa
uh the waldorf was just a great way to
for us to say hey it's time to come back
and
do it in a fun way and dance your way
back into uh
some some relaxation the ad is is very
flashy obviously but i'm wondering just
on a sort of a ground level
uh effort by the lvc va what else is
being done
to try and get not only a tourist to
come back but also uh conventions to
come back
shows to come back and try and get
things back to normal
well for us we've used a layered
approach in terms of communication so on
the meeting side of things we launched a
campaign
called fast forward back in march uh so
that's been ongoing uh we've also had
social influencers that have come to
town
we've hosted over 30 of them during the
month of march
we've also gone out and invited media in
to come and do one-on-one fans to see
the destination
and see how that people are enjoying it
safely so when we think about the
meeting side of things obviously the
west hall of the convention centers
can have its grand opening at the end of
may and the loop
uh the transportation uh innovation that
we've got at the convention center
these are things that we're talking to
our convention customers as well as
trade show executives and people are
excited to get back to
being back in life yeah everybody is
excited to get that as well
uh fletch burnell thank you very much
for joining us this morning from the
lvcva the new ad from the
convention and center convention and
visitors authority trying to get folks
to come back to las vegas
seems like it's going pretty well so far
i've been seeing this trip in downtown
it's already pretty well jammed right
now fletch
appreciate the time have a good rest of
the morning take care